hey this is preshito Walker a bottle
with a cylindrical base is partially
filled with water and placed on a flat
surface
the height of the bottle is 21
centimeters and the height of the water
is 12 centimeters
the water is completely contained within
the cylindrical portion of the bottle
if the bottle is flipped upside down
then the height of the water is 15
centimeters the question is what
fraction of the bottle is full with
water
I saw this problem on Reddit homework
help
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
at first it seems impossible to solve
the problem because we don't know the
radius of the cylindrical base and
there's no way that we can measure the
volume of the irregularly shaped top
part of the bottle
the key insight to solving this problem
is that the amount of air in both
bottles is equal
therefore let's calculate the height of
the air in the second bottle
since the total bottle has a height
equal to 21
the height of the air is equal to 21
minus 15 which is equal to 6 centimeters
so now we can imagine a bottle that's
just cylindrical
we know that it would measure 12
centimeters of just water and we would
have six centimeters of air
so from here we can figure out the
fraction of the bottle that is water
the total height of this bottle will be
12 plus 6 which is equal to 18. so the
fraction that's water is 12 over 18
which is equal to 2 over 3 and that's
the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of bind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
[Music]